gone are the days of endlessly searching
video stores for some undiscovered gem
instead it's all about endlessly
scrolling through Netflix in search of
something fresh and new to watch it's
hard to tell what's good or not so here
are some overlooked comedies from the
past few decades that are just as good
as if not better than all those big
broad blockbusters Casa de mi padre
despite being an a-list movie star Will
Ferrell isn't usually one to rest on his
laurels and do the same thing over and
over again
he likes to innovate and make good
comedy that interests him and if other
people like it great this is one of
those kinds of movies Casa de mi padre
is an exercise in both comic tenacity
and silliness as it's a parody of a
telenovela and is filmed almost entirely
in Spanish
zhenia a news sec I don't know my
buddies who come up
I mean about I'm gonna be meeting to see
that committee I think that is something
it should be noted that Farrell as a
noble rancher in Mexico doesn't speak
Spanish all that well as he deals with
both an untrustworthy brother in a
fearsome drug lord but that's all part
of the comedy before bestia goon Sean
William Scott has been largely relegated
to boolean sidekick roles such as
Stifler in the American Pie series and
as Chester in dude where's my car in
goon he's front center and often bloody
as the star of this charming hockey
comedy Scott plays Doug a dumb but
good-natured guy who works as a bouncer
and doesn't really know what to do with
his life Doug did not follow in the
family vocation he's bounced veni
discovers he has a knack for being a
hockey enforcer or goon the guy who
violently body checks opposing players
goon was written by Superbad co-writer
Evan Goldberg and knocked up star Jay
Baruchel who co-stars as Scott's best
friend little evil part light-hearted
comedy part horror movie about the rise
of a new Antichrist little evil mashes
up elements of the omen with domestic
high jinks about a newly married
sensitive modern man trying his hardest
to bond with his wife's dark and
withdrawn young son Gary just can't seem
to get five-year-old Lucas to open up to
him I'm sure it seems like we've been
moving really fast
I'm your stepfather now as it turns out
Lucas's strange ways are nature not
nurture his biological dad is the actual
devil but Gary will do whatever it takes
to fend off the forces of evil when
Satan wants Lucas back to trigger the
end of the world he's not Satan he's
just a portal to Satan and good
parenting it's about keeping that portal
shut you know your typical blended
family stuff just with a touch of evil
incarnate
I'm sorry I'm very cheery backyard
that's all right get it masterminds
usually movies that are based on a true
story are dramas but sometimes life is a
little more absurd such as the
circumstances that led to the 1997
robbery of millions from cash handling
company Loomis Fargo as demonstrated by
the events of masterminds it wasn't
exactly the crime of the century a petty
criminal named Steve convinces his
girlfriend Kelly to plan the heist by
romancing David a mild mannered Loomis
Fargo driver into being their Inside Man
and point man David makes a ton of
mistakes in the lead-up to the robbery
the robbery itself and it's aftermath
you know all in all it's a goofy crime
caper where absolutely nothing goes
right which means it's okay to laugh the
trip to Italy this low-key comedy
originated as a BBC series which was
later edited into a feature film just
like the two prequels that preceded it
the trip documented Steve Coogan and Rob
Brydon taking a restaurant tour of
northern England while the plots of the
trip to Spain and the trip to Italy are
self explanatory the series peeks with
the Italian version the British actors
and comedians play heightened more
callous versions of themselves they make
fun of each other each other's work and
engage in semi improvised comedy bits as
they scarf down handmade pasta in one
tiny roadside eatery after another
Steve's having a little sleep have a
drink so it is age you need a nap after
lunch or he gets confused
adding to the comedy and the
lostinparadise vibe is that neither
Coogan or Brighton knows much of
anything about food Bachelorette this
indie ensemble comedy might seem like a
bridesmaid's knockoff but while it
concerns a small group of close knit
friends leading up to a wedding it
actually tells an uncomfortable story
about people reckoning with the awful
things they did in the past three
friends reunite to attend the wedding of
their old friend Becky and they're more
than a little resentful that the one
they use to make fun of beat them to the
altar as the wedding draws closer many
embarrassing secrets are shared and the
main cast also manages to get up to some
cringe inducing slapstick but hey this
is a comedy about going to a wedding so
you can
that almost everything is patched up by
the end the Polka king finally a movie
about a greedy street-smart hustler that
also involves polka
that's the Polka king a true story
that's so incredibly ridiculous that it
could only be presented as a comedy Jack
Black is perfectly cast as yon LaVon
Janna jr. it's whatever you want though
which one is it okay I'm a polka band
leader and entrepreneur whose only real
crime is a blind adherence to the
American dream well that and fraud in
Poland everybody do bribe sting
in addition to his band LaVon runs a
gift shop in a record label only he
can't quite pay the bills after a chance
meeting with an elderly couple who wants
to invest in his secretly failing
enterprise he starts selling securities
with an impossibly good rate of return
but he doesn't stop there and his antics
eventually involve millions of
ill-gotten dollars